they're keeping spirits high in spite of
another outbreak of covid
some staff have had their booster jabs
for kirsty extra protection for the rest
can't come soon enough
the booster
you know anything that can keep us all
safe that that is what we need
unfortunately we do have a case in the
home and we have a couple of staff who
are off positive
and it just shows that despite being
double vaccinated
we can still get it
one and a half million people in england
are now being invited to have booster
jabs
those eligible for boosters include
people living and working in care homes
frontline health and social care staff
people over 50 and those in the more
at-risk groups
doctors say a top-up will strengthen
people's defenses and ease pressure on
the health service it's important that
we do try and contain this virus
the data is showing a slight upturn at
the moment
have been reported on a daily basis
and we can turn that round again and
make sure this is not a significant
factor going into the winter and
alongside all the other diseases we have
to look up have to manage and look after
residents at andrew cohen house in
birmingham were amongst the first to
benefit from the vaccination programme
michael hopes to get his booster soon
i'm quite looking forward to the booster
as soon as it comes i should be pleased
to have it as as the flu jab as well
anything that can prevent illness
it's got to be a good thing
millions more will be invited for
boosters in the coming weeks here they
welcome anything that could help them
reopen again
lisa dowd sky news birmingham